let's talk about Donald Trump that's
what I'm talking about with everybody
here so he looms large and Davos
conversations even though he's not here
will he be a net positive for your
business do you think that's spent time
with the administration and there seems
to be a sense that we need to help
corporate America we need to provide for
a better tax regime in the u.s. we have
the highest tax rates of OECD nations
but also an equally interesting to me
there's a sense that working together
working thoughtfully we can we can make
it more advantageous to be a public
company the number of public companies
is down by half over the last 20 years
and so it's it's time and in fact maybe
even over due to kind of rethink
regulations make sure there's not
sensible pinpoint opportunities to
improve the environment for us listed
companies I'm glad you cited the decline
in public companies I was going to bring
it up let's diagnose the problem why are
there so many fewer public companies
today than there were when it peaked in
1995 well let me let me start by giving
you almost a devil's advocate position
so the number of public companies is
down around about half the aggregate
market cap is up around about three
times so in other words the public
company model isn't broken but the
companies are much much larger and so it
says something about what is the kind of
the entry cost or what is the fixed cost
to be a pun Jobs Act was supposed to fix
that and the JOBS Act was very helpful
but you have to remember we've laid in
on a great deal of regulation some
helpful some not as helpful
sarbanes-oxley 404 required an army of
internal auditors dodd-frank the
entirety of it but title seven and and
some of the specific regulations that
companies are still wrestling with
conflict minerals sampei proxy access
all of these things including the
increasing role of activist investors
has increased the fixed cost for public
companies and it is harder for a smaller
company for a bigger company they can
hire an army of Watchers and internal
auditors for a small company it's
difficult in the shadow has grown an
enormous private financing industry how
do you so what can be done to make it
attractive enough to go public that's
staying private for longer doesn't seem
like a better idea yeah I'm glad you
mentioned that cuz I neglected to
mention that my prior answer but that
too is a contributing factor the number
of
private companies there is a more mature
financing market but like you would love
it if you were listed on the new york
stock exchange yeah you would love it a
ferry and be listed on the new york
stock exchange yeah either appears to
want to anytime soon yeah the let me
just let me just kind of pause there and
say there are very few ober and Airbnb
is in the world in other words we can
rattle them off on probably on one hand
complet private companies with nearly
unlimited access to capital but even
those companies they have employees who
join them a decade ago they were 26
years old they had no husband they had
no children they had no mortgage on
their house now they do they need some
liquidity so even those big really
exciting tech companies that people
thought where the exception that proves
the rule there ginning up the IPO
machine I'm not referring to any
companies in particular Erica and I see
the look you're giving me but you know
takes nap for instance certainly been in
the press as a perspective as a
prospective IPO so even those companies
we are seeing come public what are you
doing to win the war for the snap IPO
you know we we win where we do best is
with large IPOs because companies that
investigate when I say large IPOs
they're raising a good deal of money
let's say 500 million seven hundred
million a billion dollars or more those
companies invest a great deal of time in
due diligence to identify what's the
best venue that gives me the greatest
confidence that on the first day of my
life as a public company everything's
going to go smoothly and if you look
over the last two and a half years you
take the top 25 deals all 25 have chosen
New York's action age 20 to 25 out of 25
and so for those types of companies when
you say what am i doing specifically i'm
not going to refer to a specific company
but what we do every day for those types
of companies is make sure that model is
going to work form perfectly on day what
would you say your chances of getting
that snap IPO are today I'm not going to
comment in particular but again 25 25 of
25 of the last IPO so I'm hopeful we get
all the exciting i'm hopeful quite fun
till we get all the IPO is a qualifying
New York Stock Exchange but I feel good
about those those larger ones that care
deeply about execution of my IPO on that
first day